qu'est ce que vous pouvez me dire quand
on écrit par exemple trottinette
trottinait de tir vous trottinette terre
au tgi le dt non il ya doté au 2t i n a
eu de théo trottinette s'est dotée et 1n
tient benhaim comment comme on écrit
rhododendrons alors vous avez tk nippo
cannes bon hypokhâgne khâgne c'est dans
l'autre sens
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on n'est pas moi j'ai faute à mussy
hippopotamus j'aime manger c'est d'abord
le fanu c'est après il m'est témoin ni
beaucoup d'amis j'ai une faim dauphin va
le rejoindre au nom non allez c'est bon
en italie alors rhododendrons est rodé
au road au dedans dei c'est une banane
[Musique]
rh odeo des renders owen
moi j'utilise tout le temps mais kelly
banhars ça veut dire oh non non c'est
moi c'est plus à faire leur effet je
vais danser la floride j'ai redonné mois
des rhododendrons
donnez moi des fleurs des roses
voilà des mois des fleurs pouvoir c'est
tout c'est bien c'est plus pour tout
l'éclat rose
ah ouais c'est ce qu'ont bien quand on
voit tout nu je suis beaucoup plus pour
sophie chaos